black lives matter protesters formed
their own autonomous zone in Seattle
white liberals begin to embrace radical
chic and everything from the Washington
Monument to paw Patrol is on the
chopping block I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show event rapira show
is sponsored by expressvpn you have a
right to privacy protected and
expressive VPN calm slash Ben so I have
to admit I am now turning from be
amusement to amusement as a saying
autonomous is owned they are calling it
the Capitol Hill autonomous zone has
been set up in Seattle protesters have
taken over apparently a six or seven
block radius in Seattle and have
declared their own state they've
actually put up a sign and says you are
now leaving the USA not kidding the
Capitol Hill free zone they call it the
autonomous zone is a protester occupied
zone okay it's sort of like you Occupy
Wall Street routine that we saw a few
years back back in about 2010 and it is
going to end up exactly the same way it
happened because the police were told by
Mayor Jenny Turk into essentially
withdraw from the area and to cede the
area to the cops and it's turned into a
raucous comedy almost immediately now I
think that a lot of people across the
United States are feeling that things
have grown out of control just a little
bit but no matter how much you believe
that police brutality is wrong and
everyone who is good believes this and
no matter how much you believe racism is
wrong and you don't have to protest to
believe that racism is wrong it's kind
of weird that we are now talking openly
about a complete takeover of a major
part of a major city by protesters
against the police or apparently
according to cops some extortion is
going on the protesters have built walls
they've gone full Trump guys they've
gone full authoritarian according to
left-right they've built walls not
kidding
they actually built a wall to keep
people out they took over the east
precincts in Seattle Police Department
they called it the Seattle people's
Department which is up I'm really
enjoying this live showing on continuous
loop of The Dark Knight Rises it's
really exciting stuff they set up
physical barriers they apparently have
armed people patrolling the physical
barriers apparently they are stopping
and frisking people who are entering I'm
not kidding about this they are stopping
and frisking people who are entering and
this was to get rid of the cops guys
this was to get rid of the evil horrible
Seattle Police Department and
immediately upon that happening people
in there were like
oh you mean now there's power that's up
for grabs it turns out that anarchy is
usually a pretext for tyranny chaos is
usually a pretext for terrible people
taking over and so according to multiple
reports essentially a warlord what are
we gonna get escaped from New York
except its escape from Seattle we're
gonna send in Snake Plissken today I
mean all that has to happen here is for
is for Air Force One to be down inside
the Seattle autonomous free zone for
things to get really wild so here is
exactly what went down
according to allah pundit over at hot
air apparently Seattle PD cracked down
hard on protesters on Sunday night
despite the mayor having giving a speech
earlier that day calling for
de-escalation in order to lower the
temperature the week-long blockade by
the police of their East precinct was
lifted and demonstrators were allowed to
march past but that's not all apparently
they were afraid that the rioters were
gonna burn down a police precinct so
instead the cops in the National Guard
pulled out of the building entirely by
Monday afternoon and removed all the
equipment the files they border the
place up and they left and thus was born
a new nation the capitol hill autonomous
zone or chas for sure the country of
chas a place where progressives can
indulge in some of the most humiliating
stereotype of left-wing protest
subculture
according to reports by early Tuesday
demonstrators had established a
perimeter with improvised barriers and
deputized Scouts in the afternoon the no
cop co-op popped up slinging kebabs
snacks and free water to passers-by at
each end Square was established at the
intersection of 12th and pine bringing
out like a full Maoist regime here tents
were pitched near the precinct where
people were encouraged to stay
throughout the night or even just for
two or three hours to hold the space by
nightfall they'd built their own outdoor
cinema the crowd was energized to build
connections people spoke about investing
in black owned banks divesting from
corporations and prison reform one
speaker issued a warning about the
American Legislative Exchange Council
quote a group of usually white men from
major corporations who don't know our
issues and make laws protesters hung a
banner on the east precinct that read
property of the people according to KO
mo kamo which is one of the local
stations and there are plenty of photos
available there's even a map replete
with labels like regime occupied Safeway
regime occupied Safeway solid stuff guys
really good stuff
now people inside the
it come on this is this isn't beyond
parody it's like the right wing made
this out honestly it's as though it came
from the fever dream of like of Thomas
of Tom Wolfe I mean that that's what it
feels like
activists who are claiming to have
helped create the police no-go zone in
Seattle are now asking for food from the
outside there's an activist who tweeted
out the homeless people we invited took
away all the food at the Capitol Hill
autonomous node you got rid of law and
order and then the homeless people came
and took all your food because you're
communist and this is what happens you
stupid communist it's just it's
delicious it's delicious
like like again my bemusement so my my
outrage at the destruction of law and
order turned to the amusement as I
watched the mayor of Seattle cave to all
of this and now it has turned to
full-scale amusement as the thing turns
into a predictable debacle according to
one of the anarchists over there we need
more food to keep the area operational
please if possible bring you ready for
this vegan meat substitutes fruits oats
soy products etc anything to help us eat
yes they're starving in there because
they don't have the morning star farms
vegan breakfast products we need those
in there right now this 18 year old
activist appears to be a transgender
woman and self-described lesbian
anarchist according to her now private
Twitter account well done everybody
well I mean this is and and so what are
what are the authorities doing about
this you know because there are actual
businesses and you know people who are
not crazy who live here
so what are they doing about this
nothing mayor Jenny Durkin who watched
her office is taken over the other day
by protesters at the behest of
Councilwoman socialist Councilwoman
Shama silent who's a full-scale idiot I
mean Shama silence is a person who
occupied Boeing and asked that Boeing
stop making military materials that they
could create buses for the homeless or
something like that she's a crazy person
Shama soand so mayor Jennings irken
tweeted out in an effort this is June
8th right so three days ago in an effort
to proactively de-escalate interactions
between protesters and law enforcement
outside the East precinct chief best in
Seattle PD officers have removed
barricades surrounding these precincts
while safely securing the facility in
addition so yeah
fire has several vehicles station near
the precinct to ensure emerging medical
needs and fires are addressed if
necessary keeping this area safes is
critical
there are approximately 500 residential
homes in this block as the chief takes
this operational step will continue to
remain focused on what we can and must
do to address the systemic inequities
that continue to disproportionately
impact our black residents off so you're
gonna just let people take over a seven
block radius in your city in order to
fight inequity Wow keeping them
installations peaceful must be a joint
effort between our community members and
law enforcement now it gets better okay
like the story gets better because it is
spectacular in every possible way it is
possible for this story to be
spectacular we'll bring you all of the
details of the brand-new secessionist
country that has been established inside
the United States it's exciting exciting
stuff guys you're watching a revolution
in real time and it is it is comedy it
is high comedy guys this is high concept
comedy right here we're gonna get to it
in one second first let's talk about the
fact that you're spending an awful lot
of time consuming media these days
because have you ever seen a news cycle
like this I have not it is crazy
this is why you need a great pair of
wireless here but also to block out the
sound of your screaming children as you
tried to get some work done
you need wireless earbuds that aren't
gonna cost you a fortune are going to
fit your ear properly so I'm talking to
you about ray cons you already know ray
con your buds start at about half the
price of any other premium wireless
hereabouts on the market and that they
sound just as amazing as the other top
audio brands that you do know the newest
model the everyday a 25 year but they're
the best ones yet 6 hours of playtime
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass a
more compact design that gives you that
nice noise isolating fit ray cons
wireless earbuds are incredibly
comfortable they are perfect for
conference calls or for binging podcasts
unlike some of the other wireless
options ray con earbuds are stylish and
discreet no dangling wires or stems to
distract anybody during video calls now
is the time to get the latest and
greatest from Ray Khan get 15% off your
order at buy ray Conant comm / band that
is Bui are a YCL ENCOM slash man for 15%
off ray con wireless earbuds by rakin
comm slash men again these are great
because if a variety of fits also so you
don't have that one-size-fits-all
phenomenon where doesn't fit your ear
instead they come with a variety of fits
you can customize it just for you by Ray
come calm / Ben for 15% off the best
pair of wireless earbuds you can get ok
so Fox News had a reporter on the scene
yesterday explaining what was going on
inside this brand new country Chaz
of chess it's so good you see here's the
reporter from Fox News on Tucker's and
Tecna Carlson show last night a local
station got video of several guards
armed with assault rifles they are
asking for identification before letting
people in and police have received
reports of the armed guards demanding
money from some businesses inside their
area we also saw people passing out food
in what they call a no cop co-op and
they made a long list of demands we have
a full screen we can show you at least
some of them among them abolished the
Seattle Police Department and the court
system disarmed all cops until they are
all fired and abolished jails the
mayor's office did not respond to our
request for a request for information
about what they plan to do next so
they're allowing these crazies to take
over like this is a place where
taxpayers live this is a place where
taxpayers live so how's your whole
abolish the police thing going if you're
living in that area is it going well for
you
by the way some of the signs around the
area are things like the cops will
always be racist because capitalism
requires inequality okay so you would
imagine that there are no cops now right
I mean like this was the whole point is
to get rid of the cops wrong you are
wrong that you are the cops are there
they're just not called cops so
according to reddit people have been
posting on reddit what exactly is going
on there's a person here as Simone Rath
Simone is a rapper apparently he has
been distributing his rap mixtape - I'm
gonna read some of the comments okay you
ready this is so good
it's from a guy called wizard of the
future over reddit Raz's crew is
self-appointed heavily armed has
indicated their intention to police the
area and has engaged in the use of force
I am unaware of any rival street force
of their statue expressing the desire to
hold authority in the area a power
vacuum has apparently been filmed
apparently one of the other comes to say
I only knew him from three years ago and
he gave my staff his mixtape when he
came into our work and apparently people
are tweeting out
like Reza's becoming the very thing
people didn't want to begin with there
is a video that is out of the people
working with Raz Simone in which they
are confronting people who are
graffitiing now apparently they only
want certain places graffiti because
there's certain allies and they don't
want their businesses graffiti so weird
they want to protect the property of
people who they are allied with but I
thought that private property is bad
guys so they walk up to some people who
are graffitiing these people who
apparently work for ransom owned
allegedly work for ransom owned and the
exchange is just glorious because
remember this whole thing started about
the evils of police brutality and
authoritarianism and literally you now
have an armed force of people in this
Seattle communist area telling people we
are the police now and I will blow your
brains out if you resist so police
brutality went away for like that long
apparently and by the way Seattle cops
aren't doing that Seattle cops are not
doing that this is the these are the
woke the woke initiates the woke army
has arrived I'm starting I wanna start a
GoFundMe today any woke white liberals
who are working for mainstream media
outlets if you wish to relocate to Chas
to the Capitol Hill autonomous zone
I will help pay your way if you pledge
that you will stay there fit you can
show evidence that you are willing to
stay there for the entire duration of
Chaz's of Chaz's existence and you are
willing to subject all of your bank
accounts to the tender mercies of chaz I
am more than willing to subsidize your
your immigration to this this area
outside the United States here's a
little bit of the video that was
released about an hour long so it's been
cut down obviously this started with
people talking it ends it with a scuffle
somebody's glasses being broken
somebody's phone being broken and
somebody being put to the graph all of
this because the police are evil guys
because the police are bad please are
bad so this is better obviously I mean
come on we wouldn't want the anarchist
situation to get chaotic or anything we
need we need some tyranny so here we go
that's actually being nice and letting
this thing here I forgot we are the
police of this community now
[Music]
we are the police of this community
don't be saying no threats I'll blow
your brains out this is all from a
YouTube video that was posted by people
from inside the seattle capitol hill
autonomous zone so very very solid stuff
everybody just really really good stuff
by the way Raz simone apparently
announced that people entering ought to
be stopped and frisked remember when
stop and frisk was a bad thing because
it was the cops right the cops were bad
according to the whole story Raz Simone
a seattle local stated he belongs to the
peoples force a replacement for Seattle
PD on June 8th and a live video he
advised that unfamiliar faces should be
stopped questioned and checked to see if
they are armed which is literally the
definition of stop and frisk which is
racist right I mean stop and frisk is
bad we can't do it so according to como
news it was unusual sight Seattle Fire
Chief Harold Scoggins working with
people occupying streets in Seattle's
Capitol Hills neighborhood to close two
large rolling metal gates that lead into
the garage with the East precinct the
Seattle Police Department had a ban in
the East precinct two days earlier after
receiving threats there would be
attempts to burn it down there are no
police officers around their northern
firemen or city personnel with Scoggins
he says I was walking through someone
points it out to me the gates were not
closed they were jammed the chains
weren't working I just wanted to secure
the building he was in the center of
what's now being called the Capitol Hill
autonomous zone named by the people who
occupy it I told him this report for
como I thought was unusual a fire chief
was trying to secure a police precinct
by himself while being surrounded by
hundreds of people occupying the streets
who have shown a disdain for police he
says well we got a team we're working
through this there are some trust built
I don't want to compromise that trust
Roz Simone who some have told me is one
of the leaders in one and what many have
said is a leaderless group of protesters
and what you look around it's peaceful
everyone is show looks up for that tape
that was not quite so Joan and that lack
of an organized leadership is hampering
efforts to bring some normalcy to the
area and have officers return to the
precinct according to Assistant Police
Chief Deanna nollette know let's head
her department and other city
departments are trying to find the
leaders of the Chaz to negotiate a
roadmap for
areas immediate future you know this
roadmap should be the cops never left
that would be the roadmap by the way
they are damned lucky the Janet Reno
isn't Attorney General right now
this is where a bunch of white Branch
Davidians in Texas their compound would
be burned out by now right
but now because this is it because this
is the woke initiates we're just going
to allow a six block radius in the
center of the biggest city in Washington
state to be taken over now let's head
while Washington is an open carry state
there's no legal right for those to be
used those arms to be used to intimidate
community members because apparently
they are trying to intimidate people
trying to enter she said operating a
citizen checkpoints on a public street
is illegal she said we've heard
anecdotally of citizens and businesses
being asked to pay a fee to operate
within this area so there are reports of
an actual shakedown happening inside the
area why it seems as though the
Communist / anarchist takeover is not
all it's cracked up to be
I don't feel like injustice is being
cured guys I don't feel like this is
going well by the way what does the City
of Seattle doing about all of this
they've staff support a potty's there
they've granted all the protesters
porta-potties they've put garbage cans
and portable toilets in the vicinity for
use by demonstrators the the
demonstrators by the way are also
showing they put up a big movie screen
and they're showing ava duvernay 'he's
13th documentary from netflix about how
the prison system is evil and then ava
duvernay not having to live here of
course she puts up a message blessings
and bravery to all the good people at
Chaz tonight onward anytime ava duvernay
wants to relocate from I'm sure her posh
estate down to the the city the Capitol
Hill autonomous zone with no police
protection and if she wants to bring her
bank account with her then she is
absolutely free to do so and I very much
look forward to her to her doing that
that sounds that sounds great
what are they actually demanding so
here's the demands see one of the things
that's happened here is that there's a
there's in in semantics and in in
linguistics there's a term called
semantic overload semantic overload is
when there's a term and it's
deliberately vague so it means more than
one thing black lives matter is a
perfect example of this as my friend
Eric widen Stein has pointed out black
lives matter means something that is
perfectly obvious that we all agree with
black lives matter but it also means
something more which is you're supposed
to agree with the group black lives
matter or their demands and that's
ridiculous because the black lives
matter group is very distinct from the
message on black lives matter in fact
the black lives matter
was incredibly radical they call for
things that nobody in America wants
including Democrats they're
extraordinarily anti-semitic in their
leadership team and so the the semantic
overload for black lives matter has
become perfectly obvious so what are the
demands of the people living and and
ruling now in in this particular area of
Seattle wait until you hear these
demands because they are spectacular
they are spectacular what they demand in
order to leave free taxpaying citizens
alone in the United States of America
because they say they're no longer
living in the United States of America
they literally have a sign again that
says you are now leaving the USA and
how's that going for everybody when the
communes food is being eaten by all the
homeless and you have to ship in vegan
meat to all the protesters but get some
more of this in just one second first
when it comes to your future one of my
big bugaboos is blaming everybody else
for your future blaming everybody else
for your situation the fact is that if
you want to be successful in life make
good decisions and better yourself
really spend time bettering yourself and
better your own opportunities
one way to do that is to check out
Ashford University Ashford University
offers online bachelor's and master's
degrees programs they allow you to learn
on a convenient and flexible schedule
Ashford expert faculty teaches you
real-world skills from real world
experience in online classes built for
life's twists and turns you can learn
from home or wherever you feel
comfortable you can pursue a degree in
one of Ashford 60-plus programs like
Business Administration Healthcare
Administration and psychology with 24/7
access to your classroom daily support
and financial aid available Ashford will
give you the tools you need to help make
your dreams a reality
now's a great time to start making your
life better or I suppose that you could
blame the rest of society for all your
problems instead why don't you actually
just go make your own life better right
now dare to dream big for yourself your
tomorrow starts today at Ashford
University there is no fee to apply or
standardized test hitting required to
enroll I don't know how to ask for dot
edu slash Ben that is Ashford dot edu
slash Ben Ashford edu slash Ben and get
your journey started today ok so what
are the demands of the protesters so
free Capitol Hill has put up a piece
over at medium comm they say in credit
to the people who freed Capitol Hill
this list of demands is neither brief
nor simplistic there is no simple
request to end police brutality we
demand that the City Council and the
mayor whoever that may be implement
these policy changes for the cultural
and historic advancement of the city of
Seattle and to ease
the struggles of its people this
document is to represent the black
voices who spoke in victory at the top
of 12th and pine after nine days of
peaceful protest while under constant
nightly attack from the Seattle Police
Department well actually it wasn't
constantly attack from the Seattle
Police Department some of these protests
were protesters were getting very
violent with police so here are their
demands they want abolition of the
Seattle Police Department and the court
system abolition of it they deliberately
say we do not request reform we demand
abolition we demand the defunding and
abolition of the Seattle Police
Department and the attached criminal
justice apparatus that means 100 percent
of funding including existing pensions
for Seattle police also we want to
disallow the operations of ice in the
city of Seattle
we demand that the use of armed force be
banned entirely no guns no batons no
riot shields and no chemical weapons we
demand an end to the school to Prison
Pipeline and the abolition of youth
jails get kids out of prison and get
cops out of schools we demand that the
you new youth prison being built in
Seattle currently be repurposed we
demand that not the city government nor
the state government but that the
federal government launched a full-scale
investigation into past and current
cases of police brutality in Seattle in
Washington as well as the reopening of
all closed cases reported to the office
of police accountability we demand
reparations for victims of police
brutality in a form to be determined so
they're not actually going to explain
what they mean by that we demand that
the City of Seattle make the names of
officers involved in police brutality a
matter of public record we demand a
retrial of all people of color currently
serving a prison sentence for violent
crime by a jury of their peers in the
community so presumably this means that
if you are a black person who committed
a crime and now you're in jail they want
you retried but only if you're black and
only by a black jury we demands
decriminalization of the acts of protest
an amnesty for protesters generally but
specifically those involved in what has
been termed the George Floyd rebellion
against the terrorist cell that
previously occupied this area known as
the Seattle Police Department this
includes the immediate release of all
protesters currently being held in
prison after the arrests made at 11th
and pine on Sunday night we demand that
the City of Seattle and state government
release any prisoner currently serving
time for a marijuana related offense we
demand that they release any prisoner
serving time just for resisting arrest
we demand that prisoners serving time to
give him full and unrestricted right to
vote
we demand an end to prosecutorial
immunity for police officers
we demand abolition of all imprisonment
all imprisonment not just so they start
with youth imprisonment then they like
you know what as this goes on I have a
second thought all in prison mention
n-no more prisons we demand that the
Seattle Police Department empty its lost
and found and returned property owned by
denizens of the city we demand that all
the body cameras be turned on and all
body camera footage be made available to
the public and they want free public
housing they also would like degenerate
vacation of Seattle starting with rent
control they want free college for
everybody in the state of Washington
they want hospitals and care facility of
Seattle to employ black doctors and
nurses specifically to help care for
black patients because I know that if I
were having a heart attack first thing I
would think is I need a Jewish doctor
right now so they won't resegregate of
hospitals which is a fascinating demand
we demand the people of Seattle seek out
and proudly support black owned
businesses so we have to subsidize
specifically black owned businesses and
we demand that the city of Seattle in
state of Washington remove any and all
monuments dedicated to historical
figures of the Confederacy etc etc so
well done everybody these are the people
to whom you are catering just very very
solid stuff giving them toilets getting
them garbage cans they've taken over the
city and it's turning into a bleep show
immediately as you would as you would
predict as you would predict you know
there may come a point here where
Americans are out where it turns out
that the semantic overload that is
associated with the phrase black lives
matter if it includes nonsense like this
people can be like you know what I'm out
man I'm out of course I believe black
lives matter because duh this is
perfectly obvious but if you're
suggesting that I am supposed to buy
into this nonsense I'm gonna go no on
that but we may not have hit that point
yet because white liberals have to
demonstrate how guilty they feel see
this is all virtue signaling this is all
virtue signal even if it's demonstrate
they are actually okay with rioting and
looting otherwise they're demonstrating
their own elect privilege we'll get to
that in just one second first let us
talk about the fact that sleep is hard
to come by it these days between
everything going on in the world in the
fact you're home with your kids all the
time your kids are incredibly stressful
you probably need a great mattress this
means that when you lie down on that
mattress you'd love a mattress personal
just for you this is why you need
helix-loop-helix sleep has a quiz it
takes just 2 minutes to complete it
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you whether you are a side sleeper hot
sleeper whether you like a plush or firm
bed with helix there's no more confusion
and no more compromising helix sleep is
rated the number one mattress by GQ and
Wired magazine CNN calls it the most
comfortable mattress they've ever slept
on just go to helix sleep comm slash men
take their two-minute sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that'll give you the best sleep of your
life they even have a 10 year warranty
you get to try it out for a hundred
nights at risk-free they'll even pick it
up for you if you don't love it but
indeed you will because it was made just
for you what's not to love helix is
offering up to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders for our listeners today
up to $200 off at helix sleep comm / Ben
that is helix sleep dot-com / Ben my
wife and I have a helix sleep mattress
it's fantastic it was personalized for
us we sleep like babies on it go check
it out right now get up to 200 bucks off
at helix sleep comm slash event ok so
the these supposedly benevolent white
liberal who's willing to overlook the
nonsense that is happening right now is
not in fact helping black people it
turns out that if you want to lower
crime rates and black communities you
need police officers there that there
are some 7500 black Americans who are
shot and killed every year in the United
States and nine of them are shot and
killed unarmed by the police and if you
actually want to talk about how many
Americans are in danger you have to talk
about who actually is being shot and
killed and who is being protected and
all the rest but we are not going to do
that instead we are going to see white
politicians demonstrating their their
awareness of their own white privilege
by basically suggesting that any
behavior is tolerable so long as it
comes from people who are members of a
historically oppressed minority group
this is why you see the governor of
Washington jay Inslee he was asked about
the fact that there is now a new state
in Seattle
Chazz the state of Chaz and jnz was like
what that's not happening really like I
didn't know about that really I did yes
I am sure he did not know about that
do you remember that situation few years
back where the Bundy family got in a
standoff with the federal government
because they had been allowing their
cattle to graze on land that they had
historically been allowing their cattle
to graze on and it was endangering with
a wild turtle or something and so the
the EPA came down on them and and the
Bureau of the Interior came down on them
and they're armed standoff is a national
news story it was demonstrative of these
crazy people who are standing people off
on
ranch that was a national news story you
have Seattle being taken over by black
lives matter activists and turned into a
quasi armed police state and the
governor of the states like really me no
I have nothing to say about this here's
jay Inslee pretending he doesn't know
things protesters have taken that over
and not although I people would come and
go freely well that's news to me so I'll
have to reserve any comment about it I
have not I have not heard anything about
that from any credible source not that
you're not credible it's just like
before I spouse an opinion I should know
of which I speak okay he has no idea
what's going on it's all it's all it's
all confusing what's going on okay so
what that really is is a bunch of people
who wish to turn a blind eye to bad
behavior there's a great article by Greg
Jaffe over at the Washington Post about
this particular phenomenon and it
basically is just radical chic so back
in the 1960s there's a piece written by
Tom Wolfe the late Tom Wolfe great piece
called radical chic and the entire piece
was about Black Panthers being ushered
up to this posh penthouse owned by
Leonard Bernstein and these Black
Panthers were being shown off is almost
totems of woken us they would walk
around and they would literally say to
the white people at these parties yeah
we want to off the pigs and the white
people like oh my god that's so charming
and it's so refreshing and it's so
down-to-earth and it's it was these
upper-class white liberals being
protected by the cops who are out there
like look at look at these amazing Black
Panthers and their authenticity it's
just incredible this is what you are
getting right now from a wider segment
of the population because if you do not
bow to the narrative in America is
systemically evil and racist then
obviously you're part of the problem so
you can buy your way out of woke jail by
simply acknowledging your privilege but
only for the moment because the moment
you acknowledge your privilege
then they just resurface old stuff
you've said and they hold that over your
head forever that's the way this this
routine works so there's a piece over at
the Washington Post it is called after
killing of George Floyd white liberals
embrace ideas that once it seemed
radical did now here's the questions you
really think they're embracing these
ideas or do you think they are posturing
for the for the love of their social
media groups
now when they are actually betting down
at night they're thinking to themselves
the as the gunshots go off around the
corner man I'm so glad that I've gotten
woke I did do you think that many
Americans are thinking that right now
because again what we're talking about
here is not white support for the black
lives matter notion while we're talking
about his white support specifically in
this Washington Post piece for violence
and looting quote three days after a
police officer knelt on George Floyd's
neck killing him and only a few hours
after enraged looters ransacked a target
and torched an autozone meredith Webb
woke to an early morning message from a
close friend across the street beloved
city so much pain the text from her
neighbor Michelle Garvey read exploding
pain replied Webb who had seen the news
and cried can we talk outside in a
little while there's was a block of
mostly white liberal families tucked
inside cute bungalows with carefully
tended Gardens and century old shades
reads the two women met on the sidewalk
where their sons ages 5 and 7 had spent
much of the last few weeks racing back
and forth on their bikes and scooters on
this morning their conversations turns
to the looting and fires that had
unfolded just a few miles from their
homes to Garvey 39 the destruction of
the target and / and surrounding stores
was sad but understandable quote a
perfectly warranted and justified
response an expression of righteous rage
Webb 33 wasn't there yet she felt a
little guilty about it I wasn't sure
what side I was supposed to be on she
recalled it felt wrong to say we're with
you until you start looting why is that
wrong now the reality is that that's
exactly the right that's exactly the
right message we're with you until you
start looting is exactly the right
message we agree with what you are
basically saying about police brutality
even if you say I'm with you on police
brutality I'm not with you on systemic
American racism but say whatever you
want when you start looting it's over
man we are done no you have to suggest
that it is justified response a
perfectly warranted and justified
response in order to be initiated into
the whoa crew has anyone hasn't occurred
to anybody what a soft bigotry of low
expectations this is and when you're
angry you get to burn down a target but
only if you're a member of a particular
racial group pushing a particular racial
narrative that if Asians were angry over
affirmative action policies at colleges
that banned their kids from schools and
then went and burned down some local
stores do you think there would be any
level of sympathy for that at all the
answer of course is no it is soft
bigotry of low expectations not to say
to people you're not allowed to burn
crap down and take over in large swaths
of cities but according to the
Washington Post
there is a change in white liberal
attitudes one liberal journalist has
described it a great awoken Aang
it seems to mirror what has happened in
recent weeks in Minneapolis where
throngs of white protesters like Webb
and Garvey have taken to the streets to
cheer on black speakers as they blast
the city's police force attack it's
largely left-leaning leadership and to
cry systemic racism Webb said she turned
to Garvey for solace in the wake of that
first wave of looting and fires because
she was sad scared needed to talk with
someone in person where does this go
next she word is our neighborhood didn't
burn but she also knew her friend would
be a gut-check I didn't want to let
myself default to the simplistic
reaction of wanting this all to go away
so I guess you're not supposed to worry
about the fact that that there were
people who are you know you're worried
about burning down your house I mean the
I think the best part of this article by
the way is there is is part of the
article where they talk about police
officers okay so
Ilhan Omar showed up at a rally she said
that people were using taxpayer dollars
to call police and brutalize our young
children in our schools which is just
absurd every single person who has
remained silent and been complicit
this is the time we step up and show the
world what were made of the
congresswoman shouted yes Webb replied
about a dozen black high school students
shifted uneasily and waited for their
time to talk when it was their turn they
spoke about Charles Adams jr. the
african-american police officer who kept
their school safe and coached their high
school football team now they worried he
was gonna be forced from their school to
me I had my dad first and seconds that
his officer Adams had one student
officer Adams is like the father I
didn't have had another he makes me feel
like myself last up was a history
teacher from the school I beg you I beg
you look at these young men they came on
their own because they're worried about
their safety and losing someone they
consider a family member Webb listened
carefully
it's complicated she whispered to a
friend maybe he should be a teacher the
friend suggested maybe he could be back
Brock brought back to the school in some
other role Webb replied so basically
your budget a young black students
they're like you know what this cop he's
like a dad to me and the white liberal
walk lady she's like well I'm sorry
gonna have to stop that because you know
in the name of social justice we have to
stop that this is pure simple nonsense
it is pure simple nonsense and the white
the white woke liberal is the is one of
the dumbest species of Americans I mean
it's just incredibly dumb incredibly
incredibly done and by the way you're
not buying a space in heaven in secular
heaven for any of this all you are doing
is
is exacerbating a catastrophic leak a
otic and divisive situation and the time
when we should all be unified I keep
saying this on the show we should all be
unified instead what we are going to do
is to man things we're gonna demand that
you bow before the narrative and the
narrative of course is that systemic
racism is is endemic to the United
States if you acknowledge that then
you're no longer part of the systemic
racism but you sort of are you know cuz
you're white and all of that but if you
deny it you're for sure part of the
systemic racism Don Lemon the very
objective news anchor over it's in an
incredibly objective Don Lemon real
expert on racial issues Don Lemon he
says it's white entitlement to deny
systemic racism it's white entitlement
now does he cite any statistics to
demonstrate that systemic racism is the
problem in the United States he does not
but if you suggest that it is not then
obviously this is white entitlement so
when Thomas solo says not systemic
racism when Walter Williams is not
systemic racism when they're elders has
not systemic racism this is because they
are white splaining obviously now by the
way there is there is no the lowest
refuge of the illogical of the illogical
grifter is suggesting they don't have to
actually debunk your argument because of
who you are that they don't actually
have to come to terms with your argument
because they don't like the color of
your skin in any other guys you'd
recognize just how racist this is but
here is Don Lemon suggesting that he
doesn't have to provide evidence for his
claim because after all he's a black man
in America who's experienced bad things
and that means that anybody who says
differently on a systemic level he's up
again people are not trying to debunk
claims that you on an anecdotal level
have had bad experiences with the cops
people are pointing out that overall
there is no evidence that the police are
disproportionately shooting black people
in proportion to criminal activity or
the police are systemically racist right
the evidence for this is extraordinarily
scanty but if you say that then
apparently that's White's planning
according to Don Lemon and so you will
be made to to repent you must repent
white men denying the existence of
systemic racism
that is the essence of white entitlement
we do not need their permission or their
sign-off on what we know to be true and
what we have lived that is white
mansplaining how can you solve this
problem the systemic racism that is
killing people of color if you won't
even admit there is a problem well how
do you solve the problem when you won't
even define the problem because when you
say systemic racism is killing people of
color that is the most vague statement I
could possibly imagine how about you
name the policy that's killing people of
color or you name the person who's
killing people of color and then we can
talk about it I mean you could literally
fill in the phrase systemic racism there
with MA is killing people of color like
I don't know what that means
explain to me what that means and then I
can help but I can't help if you're just
going to shout systemic racism and then
when you say okay what do you mean by
that can you clarify what policy you're
talking about if you don't understand
it's because you're just white come on
come on now the good news is that we are
living full-scale George Orwell at this
point we're literally changing terms in
the dictionary also we are watching the
tear down of statues and these statues
are being torn down on the simple basis
not that the Confederacy was bad which
it was and evil we're talking about
tearing down statues of Columbus we're
talking about tearing down statues of
the founding fathers right this is this
is the the point is the broader
destruction of American history this is
not about a Jefferson Davis statue and
it never really was because again the
the attempts to tear down statues are
not relegated to simply old Confederate
monuments there's an argument that
cities should take those statutes
dealing I understand the argument though
should be done through Democratic means
but the the notion that first of all
protestors get to go and just take down
statues that those this is post Saddam
Hussein Iraq and you're tearing down
statues of Saddam like again the regime
that exists is a democratic is a
democratic regime in a lot of these
cities there are Democratic mayor's you
want to vote to get rid of this fine do
it seriously do it but the notion that
we are supposed to wash idly as
protesters tear down statues by always
kind of a dangerous thing as we found
out yesterday we're gonna get that I
mean physically dangerous we're gonna
get to this in just one second first let
us talk about the fact that these days
you are spending an awful lot of time
online and you may think that you are
being protected by being an incognito
but incognito mode does not actually
hide your activity it actually does not
matter what mode you use or how many
times you clear your browsing history
your ISP can still see every single
website you've ever visited which is why
even when I'm at home I won't go online
without using Express at VPN expressvpn
is an app that reroutes your internet
connection through their secure servers
so your ISP can't see the sites you
visit expressvpn also keeps all your
information secure by encrypting 100% of
your data with the most powerful
encryption available most of the time I
don't even realize I have expressvpn on
because it really doesn't slow my
computer it's very easy to install one
click of the button and you are
protected expressvpn is available on all
your devices phones computers even your
smart TV there's no excuse for you not
to be using it plus it protects you from
hackers who are looking for your credit
card info protect your online activity
today with the VPN rated number 1 by
Cena and wired visit my exclusive link
expressvpn comm slash Ben you can get an
extra three months for free on a
one-year package that's yet PR ESS VPN
comm / Ben expressvpn comm / Ben to
learn more already we have so much more
coming up in order for you to access
that you have to be a daily water
subscriber 2020 this year way oh man way
well you might need some actual
objective truth and some conservative
perspective because the fact is the
media are lying to you openly they're
rewriting history and the president does
it goes on if you are a political junkie
said on getting both sides of the story
get a readers pass today from daily
we're calm you'll get access to
exclusive op-eds from us your podcast
host as well as guest writers in-depth
analysis from our daily wire reporters
on top of our regular breaking news this
membership tier is already a bargain at
3 bucks a month but if you join today
you get that first month for $0.99 you
also get access to our mobile app your
sieve push notifications for breaking
news and special content as well as
joining the community of daily wire
members or actively commenting and
discussing our content with each other
that is mobile ad free access to all of
the daily wire news exclusive op-eds all
of our podcasts on our mobile app all
for the low price of one dollar and best
of all your dollars are getting you the
news you need without the left to spin
so head on over to daily wire.com slash
subscribe and join today also as I've
been mentioning I have a brand new book
it is coming out July 21st how to
destroy America in three easy steps
we're watching the left to do this in
real time the book isn't just about how
the left and and many and many who are
who are not even politically affiliated
are seeking to disintegrate the country
I mean we were watching the
disintegration of the country in real
time as a huge group of Americans decide
and we know long
have a shared philosophy that the
philosophy of the Declaration of
Independence and the Constitution is
evil we don't have a shared history the
history of America is exploitation and
brutality which is why we got to tear
down statues of Christopher Columbus and
we don't have a shared culture of Rights
because rights themselves are
discriminatory freedom of speech is
discriminatory because people who are
richer have more freedom of speech so we
have to quash the voice in favor of the
voiceless right all of this is
incredibly divisive it destroys the
country the book isn't just in
indictments of that of those ideas it is
a rebuttal to those ideas and a very
useful tool for you to understand
exactly what's going on in the country
and how to rebut the lies that you're
seeing in the media every single day I
think the book is deeply important you
can go to Daley wire.com slash Ben to
pre-order the book today how to destroy
America in three easy steps daily
wire.com slash Ben go ahead and
pre-order it today it already is near
the top of the Amazon charts and it's
like a month more than a month out from
publication go to Daley wire.com and
slash been pre-order today so that you
buy it while it is still in stocking you
are the first to receive it I think
again it is a deeply important book I
very rarely pitch my own work that way
but I really I think this is a it's
something that I think is is worth your
time and worth the read in this
environment how to destroy America in
three easy steps you're listening to the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so we are we are watching the Orwellian
redefinition of terms and history in
real time it's incredible
it truly is because instead of just
making an argument with you know the
language that we have constantly shared
and arguing in terms that we all
understand instead we're just going to
redefine the terms which is a very old
and very ugly trick if you redefine
terms in order to make it so that you
say well the dictionary definition of
this thing now reflects what I want to
tell ya you change the dictionary five
seconds ago a perfect example
so merriam-webster had a definition of
racism okay their definition of racism
was a belief that race is the primary
determinant of human traits and
capacities and that racial differences
produce an inherent superiority of a
particular race hey that seems like a
fairly good definition to me right it's
about racial superiority so white
supremacy is an aspect of racism right
and then merriam-webster at the behest
of a 22 year old woke stir decided to
email them is a recent graduate of Drake
University Kennedy Mitchum
she said should get into arguments with
people who pointed to that definition of
racism to support their position in
other words probably what people were
saying is if you are what I'm saying
isn't racist racism is about superiority
of one race over another or when you say
bad things about white people that's
also racist so this person emailed
merriam-webster she said I basically
told them they need to include that
there is some systemic oppression on
people it's not just I don't like
someone it's a system of oppression for
a certain group of people okay notice
this has been a longtime left-wing trope
the left-wing trope is that that racism
is not just you discriminating against a
person it is racist feeling combined
with power and this alleviates any need
to look at the racism that comes from
quote-unquote dispossessed groups so if
there is a black American who says
something racist about white Americans
like all white Americans are bad and
racist and part of a supremacist system
if you say that and a white person says
that sounds kind of racist to me you're
judging me on the basis of my skin they
say right but I'm not part of the system
of power you're part of the system of
power so I can't be racist because I'm
not part of the system of power so this
is twisting the definition I mean this
is literal Orwellian redefining of words
in order to achieve a political result
the revision would not have been made
without your persistence in contacting
us about this problem said Alex chamber
the editor
of Miriam Webster said we sincerely
thank you for repeatedly writing in and
apologize for the harm and offence
we have caused and failing to address
the issue sooner I will see to it that
the entry for racism is given the
attention it sorely needs Peter
Sokolowski and editor-at-large Miriam
Webster said in the statement the second
definition of racism Express first
explicit institutional bias against
people because of their race and second
a broader implicit bias that can result
in an asymmetrical power structure so
now they're gonna redefine racism to
mean there is a symmetry in in power or
in or in outcome and that means broader
implicit bias so again this is now
redefining the term racism to just say
that inequality is racism here you're
redefining the diction god this is too
on the nose
it's too on the nose guys I mean
honestly if you're gonna read you 1984
you really have to like tone it down a
little bit so it's a little more subtle
like foot having a full-on Department of
words to go ahead and just redefine
everything according to your lines it's
a little on the nose I got to say it's a
little on the nose the writers this
season they've been too on-the-nose
and meanwhile police are allowing people
to tear down statues just allowing it so
there's a Columbus statue that was torn
down by protestors now you might say to
yourself what does Columbus have to do
with anything was Columbus a member of
the Prudhoe Police Department was
Columbus Confederate no Columbus is bad
because Columbus represents Western
civilization arriving on American shores
that's why Columbus is bad this all goes
back to the rewriting of American
history
pushed forward by Howard Zinn so Howard
Zinn really like he begins his crappy
book a people's history of the United
States with Columbus in which Columbus
is a brutal warlord victimizing peaceful
narratives and then he says in it this
is direct quote from Howard Zinn he says
a nation a symbol illegal unity called
the United States was formed designed to
quote create a consensus of popular
support for the rule of a new privilege
leadership so America was all about
privilege in the first place he suggests
that Columbus was just Western brutality
writ small he says Columbus and his
successors were not coming into an empty
wilderness but into a world where human
relations were more egalitarian than in
Europe where the relations among men
women and children in nature were more
beautifully worked out than perhaps any
place in the world so the new world was
really not unoccupied which of course is
true but it was occupied it was
paradisiacal
it was a ruse only in paradise and then
Columbus arrived with his evil Western
civilization
and because of Western civilization
capitalist exploitation hit these shores
now let's be real about this Columbus
did some real bad stuff I Columbus did
some real bad stuff mostly the people
working for Columbus did some real bad
stuff
Columbus was more tolerant than the
people who worked for him for sure
bye-bye all available documentation but
this you don't have to excuse Columbus
his behavior to point out that the
history of humanity has been conquest
and imperialism and that existed far
before Columbus ever hit the shores of
the United States in or hit the shores
of the Western Hemisphere and existed
for a long time the only reason to
single out Columbus is particularly bad
an imperialist and terrible and
colonialist is because you don't like
Western civilization very much that's
the real reason that people are angry at
Columbus these days and this rests on
again the idea that you can take
Columbus out of history and treat him in
isolation as opposed to the fact that
human history is replete with oppression
and evil and brutality and Columbus was
involved in some of those things but it
is a very good thing on net that Western
civilization arrived in the new world
and by the way the entire Howard Zinn
narrative that everything was peaceful
and wonderful in the new world before
Columbus got there is obviously just
tripe I mean Steven Pinker writes contre
leftist anthropologists who celebrate
the noble savage quantitative body
counts such as proportion of prehistoric
skeletons with ax marks and embedded
arrowheads or the proportion of men in a
contemporary in a contemporary foraging
tribe who died at the hands of other men
suggests that pre-state societies were
far more violent than our own now this
doesn't mean the arrow wax weren't
peaceful they were by all available
evidence this does mean that if you were
going to look at history you actually
have to look at history the left never
provides context for this sort of stuff
because if they provided context then
you might be forced to judge whether
it's a good thing on average that
Western civilization rose or not by the
way claims that that Columbus genocided
Native Americans is not corrected the
depopulation of natives after contact
with Europeans was basically the result
of disease to which natives had no
immunity in the same way that one of the
reasons that Africa was originally
protected in the early days from
colonialism was specifically because
Europeans had no immunity to many of the
diseases that ran rampant in Africa okay
so in any case that's just some backdrop
so there's been this effort to tear down
statues of Columbus and this is much
worse by the way then tearing down
statues of Confederate generals and
soldiers like I actually have some
sympathy for the position that
Confederate statues should be removed
because well I don't like statues being
removed generally I don't highly
the argument I don't like statutes being
removed generally because I think that
monuments to the stupidity of man are
good I think it is good that people see
those statutes as Condoleezza Rice's
argument I think it's correct it is good
that people see those statues and point
to and say there was a time in this in
this country or people like this
slaveholders were glorified and thank
God we've moved beyond that but we
should always remember the dark history
of this country so that we can move
beyond that that seems like a reasonable
argument to me but if you are gonna
remove the statues you should at least
use to do so do so through law instead
police are just letting mobs tear down
these statues and by the way it's dams
dangerous in Richmond Virginia there are
some people who are attempting to pull
down a statue of a Confederate soldier I
guess it's an unknown Confederate
soldier and they literally pulled it
down onto the head of a protester who
may die I mean the protester came down
and cracked the guy directly on the
skull like his skull was exposed
hey this is genius stuff where are the
cops for this by the way I thought that
law and order was supposed to be a thing
you want a remote I mean yeah yeah you
want to remove these statues how about
you do so by like just going to your
legislators there are open discussions
right now in Mississippi by the way
between Democrats and Republicans about
changing the state flag doing stuff
through democratic means is a good thing
going and tearing down statues by
yourself not a good thing and you know
what else is not a good thing allowing a
statue in in Minneapolis that was
crafted by an Italian immigrant who
helped build Grand Central Station and
his son who's given during the Great
Depression as a symbol of the acceptance
of Italian immigrants in Minnesota
according to Ben's dominance at the
Federalist protesters this isn't a
protest by the way this is an act of
vandalism yanked down at Christopher
Columbus statue outside the Minneapolis
State Capitol in st. Paul yesterday the
police were warned about this like 90
minutes in advance and they did nothing
they did nothing
one order has completely disintegrated
completely this integrated I mean the
video is pretty astonishing again where
are the cops where are the cops even if
you think the Christopher Columbus
statue ought to be removed which I do
not even if you think that that's the
case allowing protesters to just run up
and tear down monuments they don't like
that's not law and order that is not
living in a civilized society by the way
if you think it's gonna stop here a
taint there's certain black leaders who
are calling for the Washington Monument
and Jefferson Memorial to be removed
because after all we have to talk about
the fact that they were slaveholders and
we can't put them into historical
context and points out that slavery was
the
a lot of man throughout the 18th century
we cannot point out that the actual
monuments that were built to Washington
and Jefferson do not honor slavery they
honor their contributions to human
freedom that have come to full fruition
in the United States instead we got to
talk about removing statues of the
founding fathers removing America's
history is the key because American
history is bad and wrong and evil and
that's the agenda here the agenda is not
alleviating pain it is excoriating
American history and suggesting we have
nothing in common but the revolution
here are actively here the Angela Wright
another commentator suggesting that it's
time for the takedown of Jefferson
statues in the Washington Memorial
American history is not all glorious and
and even though I love John to death I
couldn't disagree more about George
Washington George Washington was a slave
owner and we need to call slave owners
out for what they are whether we think
they were protecting American freedom or
not he wasn't protecting my freedom I
wasn't someone who my ancestors weren't
deemed human beings to him and so to me
I don't care if it's a George Washington
statue or at Thomas Jefferson statue or
a robert e lee statue they all need to
come down they all need to come down all
of american history needs to come down
you can't see America is the story of an
attempt to fulfill our founding
philosophy to which America fell short
no all of it has to come down all of it
has to come down and so we are doing
this with with monuments we are doing
this with culture we are doing this in
every aspect of American life when
people signed on to the black lives
matter slogan they did not sign up for
this
they didn't when people signed up for
the we care about black lives and don't
want to see black people killed
that was not signing up for America is
systemically evil and racist and
horrible in every possible way and tear
down the Washington Monument
no one signed up for this no one signed
up for this or if they did it is a vast
minority and the media's attempt to
broaden that out to a majority is gonna
be wildly unsuccessful and by the way
counterproductive because whatever you
are trying to do you're gonna need some
level of unity to accomplish it instead
you've decided that the narrative was
more important than any actual change
you want to undermine change make the
agenda so broad that nobody agrees on it
and that's exactly what's going on right
now okay meanwhile the the culture is
fragmenting as well because everything
has to be removed now everything has to
be removed
not just the statues okay not and we're
not even talk about statues of
Confederate generals we're talking about
statues of George Washington and
and Thomas Jefferson those have to be
removed but not just those we now have
to make sure that no one ever sees a
depiction of a good cop cops have to be
perceived as uniquely evil in American
life how crazy has this become does it
become so crazy that protesters are
coming for paw patrol paw patrol you
stupid asses paw Patrol are you kidding
me come for McGruff the Crime Dog here
paw patrols a children's cartoon
according to the New York Times about a
squad of canine helpers it's basically a
pretence for placing household pets in a
variety of cool trucks the team includes
Marshall a firefighting Dalmatian rubble
a bulldog construction worker and chase
a German Shepherd who's also a cop in
the world of paw patrol chase is drawn
to be a very good boy who barks stuff
like chase is on the case and all in a
police pups day as he rescues kittens in
his tricked-out SUV but last week when
the show's official Twitter account put
out a bland call for black voices to be
heard
commentators came after Chase euthanized
the police dog they said defund the paw
patrol all dogs go to heaven except the
class traitors in the paw patrol it's a
joke but it's also not says the New York
Times as the protests against racist
police violence entered their third week
the changes are mounting against
fictional cops - even big-hearted
cartoon police dogs or maybe especially
big hearted cartoon police dogs are on
notice the effort to publicize police
brutality also means banishing the good
cop archetype which relies on both TV
and in viral videos of the protests
themselves which rains on both TV and in
viral videos paw Patrol seems harmless
enough and that's the point the movement
rests on understanding that cops do
plenty of harm what we actually need is
we need a more accurate depiction of paw
patrol apparently what we need is for
chase the good German Shepherd to
apparently be chasing down like only
puppies of color like that that's what
we actually need in order to reflect the
evils of America's policing system like
this is such bullcrap
I'm sorry did anyone sign up for this
anyone and isni fans are saying that
Splash Mountain needs to update because
it's racist Splash Mountain is racist
now maybe you've been on Splash Mountain
and maybe you thought yourself wait a
second there there are no people in this
ride how's it like literally no people
in this right it's all animals how's
this racist exactly well let me tell you
it includes a song is it buddy doo-dah
you know the song did you know that that
song came originally from a 1946 film
called song
of the south that is considered to be
racist because it relies on stereotypes
of black people and a nostalgic view of
the antebellum South did you notice this
you didn't because it's not in the ride
you didn't notice this okay so maybe the
song came from the racist film 41946
also did you know that did you
I did cuz I'm Disney aficionado but did
you know that did any of the millions
and people who visited splash met were
they going through Splash Mountain
thinking themselves oh man man is this
ride about a fox and a bear and an
alligator and everything every time I go
down that giant drop I think to myself
god systemic racism in America is that
really really fans have offered to a
solution to redeem at the ride one fan
took to Twitter to showcase his concept
for a princess and the frog theme genius
beautiful beautiful stuff guys you're
really making America a better place by
destroying Splash Mountain excellent
excellent work everyone just slow clap
slow clap for making the culture a
better place guys great stuff also Amy
is canceling live PD which makes perfect
sense because live PE also has a segment
near the end of the show about missing
children so it's good to take shows off
TV that actually try to help missing
children at the end because we can never
have any depictions of cops that are
good cops are uniquely bad and the fact
of this is going to be that that cops
are just not gonna join forces I mean is
what's gonna happen you're gonna see a
massive drop-off and the number of
people who join police forces according
to according to a any live PD host Dan
Abrams went to all of you asking whether
live PD is coming back the answer is yes
all of us associated with the show are
is committed to it as ever we are still
discussing some specifics but I want to
assure you the live PD nation that we
are not abandoning you but the network
and production company came to the
conclusion there's no path forward for
the show in its current form as
protesters and politicians are calling
for a police reform following the death
of Floyd I mean is it great stuff so Dan
Abrams said shocked and beyond
disappointed about this to the loyal
live PD nation please no I we did
everything we could to fight for you and
for our continuing effort and
transparency in policing so we've taken
down live PD excellent work everyone
u.s. soccer by the way is now going to
allow any lien which makes perfect sense
because US soccer represents the United
States that makes perfect sense
it is a soccer team that is literally
called u.s. soccer
so it makes perfect sense that you would
allow people to kneel for the American
flag in the national anthem while
playing them for US soccer
imagine for a second that US soccer were
not US soccer it were Nike and the
players just said you know what Nike
does child labor it breaks child labor
laws so I'm wearing Reeboks on the field
you think Nike stands for it for half a
second they kneel for the Nike slogan
every time there's a swoosh that comes
across the giant scoreboard everybody's
kneels you think anybody goes for that
but apparently the US Soccer Federation
has now repealed the lease three year
old ban on kneeling during the national
anthem US Soccer said it has become
clear that this policy was wrong and
detracted from the important message of
black lives matter again black lives
matter does not require you to kneel for
the national anthem
black lives matter the message not the
group black lives matter does not
require you to kneel for the American
flag none of that is required but the
idea is that you have to be okay with
people kneeling for the flag if you
believe that black lives matter which is
an asinine contention hey how bad is the
stupidity getting it's getting so stupid
that the American Statistical
Association everyone is forced to comply
I've gotten so many notes from people at
who are working in major corporations
and companies who are now being
force-fed
propaganda about how America is
systemically racist and if you do not
acquiesce to that idea then your your
your job may be on the chopping block
the workers are in control it's it's so
funny we've been told that corporations
are the repository of all capitalist
right-wing evil in the United States
ain't seen a lot of that these days are
you what I'm saying is t.j.maxx putting
out statements about how woke they are I
mean like every single corporation
putting out statements why because
they're a bunch of staffers inside will
then go on the interwebs and whine about
how their company is not taking a strong
enough position because I needed to know
the t.j.maxx wasn't interested in white
supremacy is big for me like in the when
gushers did that the other day I thought
to myself oh good now you know that now
I feel now I just feel so much better
eating a gusher now the gushers have
spoken out about black lives matter and
it's not just that it's trying to
retrain all of their employees in a
particular political viewpoint is any of
this really going to foster unity or is
it gonna foster a backlash that is going
to be bad when we could all agree on
some stuff the American Statistical
Association which promotes the practice
and profession of statistics put out a
statement we the three elected
presidents of the American Statistical
Association
are deeply moved by the tragedies and
social upheaval that have unfolded in
the past few weeks as felt by many of
you we too are angered anguished and
wearied as new names are added to the
dreadful roll call of black individuals
slain harmed or threatened by law
enforcement or by vigilantes as allies
we stand with African Americans and
other communities of color as we work to
overcome systemic racism in America now
I've a question is the American
Statistical Association do they cite any
stats in this no no no stats at all no
you just say systemic racism and now
we're all supposed to just go okay I
know exactly what you mean great job
everybody
great job by the way scientists when
didn't didn't work this week they didn't
work yesterday because supposedly
science is racist to it we are living
through an extraordinarily chaotic
moment we are living through a moment
when unity has been transformed into
disunity because the narrative that
people are attempting to draw is not in
consonant with fact and if you mention
this fact then you're immediately
declared to be white splaining well how
about rebut the arguments instead of
just judging anybody on the color of
their skin seems to me that that should
be a modicum of respect that every
individual citizen in the United States
deserves alrighty we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours of
content you're listening to the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling assistant
director Pavel wideouts key technical
producer austin stevens playback and
media operated by Nick Sheehan associate
producer Katy Swinton edited by Adam SCI
events audio is mixed by Mike or Amina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20/20
leftist riders tear down more statues
and Tifa creates its own police force
and gone with the wind gets cancelled to
80 years after it premiered also the
mailbag check it out in the Michael Dahl
show
[Music]